ja
freut ihr euch
ich hab's zurücklag heute geht so
richtig los leute denn wir haben ein
surgery training und müssen einer person
ein
hsv-keeper kleßheim box blatt
bobs beines kaputt zitiert
[Applaus]
nicht sollen sein bein arm reich sein
keyboarder geschieht
warum kommt das feuerwerk auch ein petit
monsieur com
ich bin auch der schlechteste arzt der
welt sowie wir nehmen seinen beinen und
schmeißt es hier ein wo kommt das bei
der ich habe es verstanden
von ihm aus gesehen das rechte bein das
hätten wir bommer sein sagen können so
und sagt sie ganz schnell sein abreißen
sagt dass bei der hornbahn dass bei
nehmen wir da rein
[Musik]
ich bin dabei
wenn ich hab mal nehmen
[Musik]
wenn wir nicht einverstanden
ich wusste nicht dass sein atem direkt
versuchen die erde habe ich so und jetzt
was machen wir jetzt mit dir jetzt mache
ich einfach gehen sie also jetzt mal
ganz kurz real talk es muss doch
irgendwo jetzt stehen was ich machen
soll oder durch harry potter sein arm
zurück ja dann lassen wir den abend da
liegen
ach so ich glaube ehrlich gesagt dass
box geringstes problem ist dass er
gerade blutet okay ganz von vorne die
nehmen uns sein
dass auf dem großen onkel da wir nehmen
uns jetzt ganz vorsichtig sein bein und
schmeißen es hier rein jetzt haben wir
die spritze und hauen wie bei ihm habe
ich so und jetzt und jetzt
ob jetzt schüttelt er den kopf da nicht
so dann muss derzeit durch ja was machen
wir denn jetzt mit bob also ich bin ganz
ehrlich ich kann da kann ich einfach
noch ausbau neuer arzt vom dienst
natürlich selbstverständlich immer
professor unterwegs wir laufen uns
einfach mal zurück können wir hier noch
was machen
hier ist aber ich komme gleich wieder da
ich habe jetzt das passende buch geholt
damit kriegen wir dich jetzt repariert
ich sag's euch ich sag's euch da stehen
die ganzen live extreme idee ab ob das
was zum lesen bob das ding hier leuchtet
grün das heißt es könnte theoretisch
sein dass wir uns jetzt das bein
hinnehmen müssen weil das ja anscheinend
neues und das irgendwie dran gehört man
das ist doch nicht war hier mit diesem
volltrottel sie sich nicht selber
operieren
das schloss soll wir nehmen seinen
beinen und packen sein bein sein
[Musik]
professionalität
geht hier ganz groß geschrieben drei
wochen später
von a
wir können hier durch so perfekt und
jetzt gegen mittag oder letzte wenig
spaß
ich hasse blutiger das was an das auch
passieren weitermachen
aber mir war schon immer sehr wichtig
dass man ja hier ist hat der neue jetzt
macht dran
das wär doch mal was du musst auch ein
bisschen schnell wieder an sich auch
nicht alles alleine waren
wir können jetzt weiter gehen und keine
ahnung was wir dann machen müssen
wahrscheinlich müssen wir die kettensäge
nehmen und seine allerdings würde ich
sagen dass wir das in der nächsten folge
machen von doktor professor mediziner
luca von lemberg ist arzt
wenn ihnen termine meiner praxis wollt
dann schreibt ein kommentar
[Musik]